okay so yeah i'll be speaking about uh
georgia tool uh the tool that is used to
analyze spatially resolved
transcriptomics the
method that was uh named the method of
the year by nature
um
well
it was a great breakthrough when
a single cell was developed compared to
bug dna it allowed us to
specifically study separate cells
but when we
analyze data using single cell we end up
with something like this
just uh
cells in an artificial dimensions in
this case it's umap but we never really
know where exactly in our tissue the
cells are located
um and with spatial transcriptomics
finally we have this opportunity to map
the cells to our tissue like here this
example this is the
kidney
and this is normal kidney uh injured
kidney and
another
injured kidney and we can see that for
example our cortex is comprised of a
mixture of different cells that are
located here the glomerular
or the collecting ducts
and our
other cells for example proximal tubular
cells this third segment is located
here it's pretty much all the outer
medulla is comprised only of this type
of cell
but other than organs we also can look
at for example biofilm populations
this is the clustering of different
functions that cells individual cells in
the colony
do and
use it in spatial transcriptomics it was
possible to map them to the specific
positions in the colony which allowed to
identify some hot spots for functions
for example here we can see that this
hot spot does the gender
denitrification here we can see it's hot
spot for high oxidative stress and so on
of course it's not the only application
of spatial transcriptomics it's used a
lot in medicine for example in studies
of cancer because tumor is very
heterogeneous and there are different
clones some parts are evolving faster
and of course we can see some
differences in expression
also it's very useful to identify the
invasive margin of the tumor and
actually how the cells this
uh cancer interact with normal cells
and it was possible to build a bunch of
expression atlases for healthy organs or
the ones in disease
also in molecular biology
it allowed to
localize the individual
molecules and of course study their
expression inside the cell for example
in cytosol or in nucleus
also help to understand better the
chromatin organization and cell
development
so there are different experimental
platforms
to study spatial single cell
we can separate them into microscopy
based methods like segfish austin fish
or murfish all the hybridization based
methods and sequencing based methods for
example division
the difference is that for microscopy
based methods since it's based on
hybridization we can we have a single
cell or even single molecule resolution
and thus we can identify their locations
if it's in cytosol or a nucleus or
somewhere else
um
but we are restricted to only known
genes
and we cannot
study any novel ones and we also
continue lies too many genes at the same
time because we are restricted in number
of colors or they can just basically
overlap and we won't see exactly where
this molecule is
sequence and base methods are easier and
cheaper and they don't really need
a lot of pictures
made on microscop to study not the
locations
and we also can
study novel genes that we don't know the
sequence of
but it's not always a single cell
resolution and we will be focusing on
vision that is
exactly not single cell resolution
but uh basically how vision works we
have a plate
like this and the capture area that is
comprised of small spots
and each spot already has the barcodes
the spatial barcodes that will tell us
where exactly
this position is located so we place our
tissue above the
the capture area and we treat it so the
mrna will ligate to our barcodes
and
then we just proceed to sequence and we
get stick ones like this
so after sequencing we end up with our
metrics where we have gene counts per
cell and cell coordinates
and of course we can get some pictures
to work with as well
so um
with the data i just showed we can start
our pipeline and um spatial
transcriptomics actually very similar at
the beginning it's very similar to
single cell analysis it also has the
preprocessing steps the dimension
reduction
different clustering or
algorithms and different
algorithms for
cluster-specific marker gene
identification
cluster annotation
but um giotto also allows us to
check
to play with clusters to separate them
or to merge them based on their
similarity
and run enrichment
and this module the spatial analysis is
what is really different and interesting
for us
um it starts with a building spatial
network and then we can uh find
spatially variable genes that
have some spatial pattern
and study coexpression and cell night
neighborhood so um i will focus only on
this part
so
um we already did all the pre-processing
single cell analysis and ended up with
our artificial
dimensions in this case it's umap
and we color them with laden clustering
so in this case we have 11 clusters this
is kidney
sample
and what is different from single cell
at this moment is that we already can
map our cells on our
tissue and we see here that for example
clusters six and seven comprise the
inner medulla and classes two and nine
comprise the outer medulla and the rest
of the classes comprise the cortex and
it's really a mixture of cells
what we can
see here is for example we can plot how
many genes are expressed by which
part of our tissue and we see that
medulla is
expressing a lot more transcript than
the chord attacks
so the first step in spiritual analysis
is to applaud a spatial grid or network
that will allow us to
calculate their relationships between
these parts in case of grid this is um
the expression will be summarized inside
the grid and for in case of network it
will
remain as a single
cell or single spot resolution
and this allows us to run
spatial
spatial gene
search
and i wanted to show you example of two
genes snaps and gpx3 which are both
marker genes of proximal tubules
but you can see on these plots that they
actually have completely different
spatial expression patterns right we can
see gpx3
expressed in the cortex and not
expressed in the medulla and napsa is
expressed in out for medulla
so um comparing it to already known um
cell types in the kidney we can see that
actually gpx3 is
a marker gene for proximal tubules but
segments one and two which are located
in the cortex and napsa is more
correlating with uh proximal tubules the
segment three which is located here in
the outer medulla so spatial analysis
can help us understand marker genes
better
also the next thing is spatial
coexpression
so this actually allows us to identify
the metagenes a group of
genes that are
sharing same patterns of expression and
for example for this data set
this study said eight
metagenes were
were identified and here we can see
the
correlation between these g eight methyl
genes and here are
the expression
for the
medicines on our tissue and you can see
that they all have uh different uh
patterns of expression some are specific
to inner medulla some are specific to
outer metallus some are specific
all not quite because the here is a
mixture of cells really but they're
specific to the cortex and we can go
from the
metagen medical gene level to single
gene level if we want to
and one more
maybe the most interesting thing is how
the cells interact and in this case um
it shows how really
well the first step is to find the
interaction changed genes so the genes
that actually in
change
when
their expression changes when there is
interaction with different cells
and based on these genes we can find
cell types that are interacting within
this cluster or with other clusters
and we can say for example that clusters
4 5 8 1 and 3 they all are here
they aren't really
correlating even to each other very well
and um
for example cla cluster 10 and 11 these
are small ones they're located here and
here
they have very strong
interaction inside the cluster and not
so much with other clusters well they
interact with each other as well
so um
a spatial single cell really gives us a
lot of opportunities to study
um pretty much anywhere we can apply
single cell we can try applying switch
to a single cell and it will give us
more information at where exactly this
function
is happening and
a lot of a lot of information about
expression
uh patterns spatial expression patterns
so um that's it on the geode